Hello?
Hey, Amanda.
What's up?
Nothing much.
Where are you?
I'm at a hair salon to dye my hair.
Really?
What color are you changing it to?
I want it blonde.
It will be cute with my bangs.
Are your friends and family okay with your decision?
Why not?
Besides, it'll grow back.
That's right.
Is anybody with you at the salon?
With my friend.
He is waiting for me.
By the way, how long is your hair?
Me?
I've got shoulder length hair.
That's pretty.
Do you have wavy hair?
Yes, that's right.
I think wavy hair makes you look younger.
Do you think so?
I thought straight hair makes you look much younger.
Should I straighten my hair or not?
Well, either way, I'm sure you'll look beautiful.